bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
sport et on commence avec les titres de
cette édition à 45 ans Chantal descoin
joué le dernier match de sa carrière
avec l'Entente le chaîné Versailles
samedi soir nous y étions l'esprit
sportif partagé 78 a lancé sa campagne
vendredi 4 avril nous en parlons sur ce
plateau ce soir avec nos invités enfin
le titre de champion de France de prob
pour les filles du club de tennis de
table d'élencour attention les images
sont
spectaculaires en fin d'émission comme
d'habitude tous les résultats sportifs
du weekend mais avant cela on ouvre la
page
basket
à 45 ans et après 40 ans de carrière
Chantal Descoins de l'Entente le chaînet
versaill faisait ses adieux samedi soir
à montboron une véritable page qui se
tourne à le LCV Jonathan villman pour
les
images une vie consacrée à sa passion à
45 ans Chantal Descoins basketteuse de
l'Entente le chaîné Versailles tiré sa
révérence à samedi soir au gymnase de
montbouron après 40 ans de carrière une
longévité impressionnante à un tel
niveau mais pour terminer sa route en 3e
division Française de Basket Féminin
Chantal des coins n'a rien laissé au
hasard une hygiène de vie irréprochable
du sport et encore du sport d'ailleurs
elle l'avoue elle en est accro même si
les entraînements commençaient à devenir
pesants j'ai besoin de ça quoi en fin de
compte si je le fais pas je suis pas
bien quoi c'est un peu comme une drogue
ouais ouais contente d'arrêter parce que
c'est pas les matchs qui qui m'ennuient
c'est les entraînements qui les trois
entraînems par semaine les déplacement
donc c'est çao que les match je
continuerai à venir le samedi la joueuse
laisse derrière elle un beau palmarès de
titres de championne de France et des
matchs en Coupe d'Europe avec le Stade
Français versaill une montée en National
une avec le chaîn Chantal DESCO plus
qu'une simple joueuse une compétirice
qui ne pense qu'à la gagne c'est une
page qui se tourne c'est une joueuse
exceptionnelle je dirais tant dans
l'esprit que dans l'entraînement elle
est toujours présente toujours
combattive toujours à fond c'est ce que
disait le président tout à l'heure la
passion de son sport et être joueuse
c'est une joueuse on fait un jeu à
l'entraînement à joue
compte les points jamais perdre toujours
à fond la suite Chantal Descoins
continuera de l'écrire avec ses petits à
la maternelle où elle est institutrice
pour le basket il lui reste encore
quelques matchs à disputer avec l'équipe
réserve du chaîné en Excellence
régionale et l'an prochain si l'équipe a
besoin de joueus à l'entraînement pas
question pour la quadragére de se
défiler de toute façon Chantal des coins
lâche jamais
rien nous en parlions dans les titres la
campagne esprit sportif partagé 78 s'est
lancé le 4 avril autour de l'esprit
sportif basket football handball et
rugby veulent s'entendre pour promouvoir
le fairplay et le civisme sur les
terrains à mes côtés pour en parler
Philippe FME président du comité des
ivelines de basketball bonsoir Philippe
bonsoir pierre gubaau trésorier général
du district de football des ivelines
bonjour bonsoir Armand Perrier président
du comité de rugby des yvelin bonsoir
bonsoir et Patrick sheab président du
comité de handball desiveline bonsoir
Patrick bonsoir et Luc miseray Direction
Départementale de la Cohésion Sociale
bonsoir bonsoir alors déjà messieurs
avant de commencer une petite apartée on
vient de voir un sujet sur Chantal
Descoins qui a annoncé la fin de sa
carrière je me tourne vers Philippe
femme qui connaît bien Chantal Descoins
euh avec son départ c'est une vraie page
qui se tourne sur le basket EV Lunois
alors effectivement c'est une page qui
se tourne mais déjà Chantal des coins
c'est une exccep sportive comme le
reportage l'a dit 40 ans de de basket
elle a démaré à 5 ans elle termine sa
carrière on va dire de compétirices à 45
ans donc 40 ans effectivement de de Bono
et au service au service de peu de club
puisqueelle a commencé à Évreux tout
près de la région parisienne ensuite
elle est venue sur le versaill où elle
est allé jusqu'au plus haut niveau avec
le Stade Français versaill jusqu'en
Coupe d'Europe à l'époque où
effectivement le Stade Français
Versailles portait où les couleurs du
basket féminin français et puis puis
elle est partie un petit un petit peu
assaut pour revenir terminer sa carrière
toujours à Versailles mais dans le cadre
de de l'Entente le chîn versaill elle
fait monter en National où elle a fait
monter en National 2 et puis
effectivement ensuite National 1
puisquelle elle faisait partie de
l'équipe qui qui la saison dernière est
monté en Nationale une donc la 3è
division féminine derrière la la Ligue
Féminine professionnelle la Ligue 2 et
ensuite la nationale une donc un exemple
pour pour tous et pour toutes un exemple
de longévité et un exemple d'esprit
sportif et un exemple d'esprit sportif
effectivement et ça fait la bonne
transition avec la suite de du reportage
alors justement on revient au vif du
sujet ce lancement vendredi 4 avril je
le disais de la campagne esprit sportif
partagé 78 150 personnes se sont réunies
à l'amphithéâtre condorsé de
l'Université de Versailles à
Saint-Quentin à guillancour Messieurs je
vais me tourner vers Luc miseret de la
Direction Départementale de la Cohésion
Sociale d'où est venue cette démarche
innovante de créer un esprit sportif
partagé 78 mais il y avait une volonté
d'agir davantage c'est quelque chose
qu'on que l'on évoque régulièrement et
puis il nous semblait qu'il manquait
quelque chose pour faire en sorte qu'on
passe à un nouveau cap et donc là a été
mise en place donc un partenariat avec
les quatre sport collectifs majeurs on
va dire sans dénigrer les autres pour
essayer d'agir concrètement et donc il y
a des formations qui ont été mises en
place pour qu'on se réunissent qu'on
échange qu'on mutualise un peu les
expériences et qu'en même temps on
acquière de de nouvelles connaissances
de de nouveaux savoirs faire de nouveau
savoir-être de nouveau savoir vivre pour
faire en sorte que la compétition
s'exprime mieux la compétition qui
s'exprime déjà bien puisque l'essentiel
des matchs se passe correctement on
voudrait que ces matchs là se passent
encore mieux et puis là où il y a des
difficultés parfois et ben trouver le
moyen de réduire ces problématiques et
de faire en sorte
que le jeu ressorte davantage alors
c'est ça on va parler du public à qui
s'adresse cette initiative finalement
dans les ivelines les chiffres 300 clubs
61000 licenciés 700 arbitres voici pour
les principaux chiffres je crois que ce
sont aussi les les parents qui sont
visés c'est ça alors les les parents
tout le monde mais le ce que font
remonter les comités c'est que il y a
notamment euh un une évolution
relativement négative de ce point point
de vue là c'est-à-dire de de de de gens
qui en fait ne respectent ni le jeu ni
les enfants puisque la plupart du temps
c'est les enfants dont il s'agit ni les
règles du jeu ni les arbitres et donc à
partir de ce moment-là c'est toute
l'évolution sportive qui est compromise
donc c'est effectivement un sujet qui
est très très préoccupant et donc pour
trouver le moyen de de juguler ça
souvent les les clubs sont un peu
démunis par rapport à ça ben il semblait
important qu'on se réunisse et qu'on
travaille ensemble sur ce sujet et
d'autres alors justement je vais me
tourner vers Philippe femme maintenant
comment on on peut mettre en place cet
esprit sportif partagé je crois qu'il y
a des modules de formation qui vont être
mis en place dès le plus jeune âge c'est
ça alors
effectivement l'idée déjà c'est c'est
d'essayer de faire en sorte que cet
esprit partagé d'ailleurs qui est le
l'envers de l'incivilité parce que nous
on préfère posi que négativé puisque
effectivement au départ notre démarche
cétait d'essayer de prévenir les
incivilités dans le sport mais très
rapidement on s'est dit que il fallait
valoriser positiver la démarche et on a
préféré plutôt prendre comme slogan
l'esprit sportif et puis comme nous
sommes qure sport collectif de ball
c'était la première fois que ces qure
sports travaillaient ensemble on s'est
dit le mot partager tombe bien et puis
78 parce que nous sommes dans dans les
éeline et que c'est un petit peu une
tête de pont pour la suite des
événements peut-être au niveau régional
voire même F
mais en réalité notre objectif c'est
effectivement au travers d'un d'une
première mesure concrète qui est un
module de formation donner aux acteurs
qui sont au centre de cette démarche
c'est-à-dire les entraîneurs les
techniciens et les arbitres la capacité
de sentir les choses de prévenir plutôt
que de guérir en réalité on sait que les
entraîneurs les éducateurs pour les plus
petits parce que à ce momentlà on les
appelle pas des entraîneurs on les
appelle des éducateurs et bien ils sont
je dirais au cœur des jeunes au cœur des
parents puisque gén généralement c'est
eux qui ont le premier contact avec ces
publics là et que si on leur donne
quelques outils pour effectivement mieux
faire passer les messages on est
persuadé que dans la suite au niveau des
des des parents qui sont dans le public
au niveau des jeunes qui sont sur le
terrain les choses vont aller de mieux
en mieux et puis des jeunes qui sont
bien éduqués on imagine que quand ils
deviendront plus grands ils continueront
à transmettre je dirais la bonne
démarche alors ça c'est vis-à-vis
effectivement des techniciens et des
arbitres et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce sont nos premiers nos
premières cibles en terme de formation
avec les dirigeants car sans les
dirigeants et sans les présidents de
club toute façon c'est un 20 mot que de
dire on va essayer de partager l'esprit
sportif il est clair que nous comités
départementaux district de football on
ne peut pas à nos niveaux agir c'est sur
le terrain et sur le terrain ce sont les
clubs et sur les dans les clubs ce sont
les présidents et les dirigeants qui
mènent la la la la la balle si j'ose
dire dans ce cadre-là ce module
comportemental qui est un module sur le
savoir-être c'est-à-dire en réalité
aujourd'hui nos techniciens nos orbitres
sont toujours formés sur le savoir-faire
donc le code de jeu la technique mais en
réalité on leur donne jamais des outils
qui leur permettent de mieux réagir en
fonction d'événements qui interviennent
non pas sur le plan technique mais sur
le plan comportemental donc on va
essayer effectivement de leur inculquer
des certaines bases qu'ils pourront
répercuter sur le terrain vous parlez du
district de football je vais me tourner
vers pierre gubaau euh pierre Guibo je
voulais je voulais vous parler du du
football dont vous vous occupez il y a
souvent de la violence dans dans le
football c'est un fait vous êtes un peu
le mauvaise élève du du sport
aujourd'hui c'est le le sport qui
souffle qui souffre de la plus mauvaise
image à l'heure actuel en France est-ce
que ce genre d'initiative peut apporter
justement au football bien sûr alors
comme vous dites souvent non non il y a
pas beaucoup de d'incidents un tout
petit pourcentage mais forcément le
nombre faisant on arrive effectivement à
avoir quelques incidents qui sont
parfois dramatiques euh et on travaille
d'ailleurs à l'intérieur du district des
Yvelines la Ligue de Paris aussi euh
contre les incivilités mais euh ce genre
de d'initiative
euh ça peut permettre aussi euh on n'y
pense pas les les enfants peuvent
changer de sport de temps en temps aller
jouer au basket une année aller au foot
après jouer au rugby enfin et euh notre
projet commun euh fait que ces
enfants-là retrouveront toujours on
l'espère le même discours de de l'esprit
sportif et euh comme le disait le
président femme ben quand ils sont
arrivés quand ils seront arrivés adultes
ce discours ils l'auront euh bien bien
dans leur tête et ils pourront
l'appliquer et ils l'appliqueront déjà
depuis depuis plusieurs années et ils
pourront l'appliquer euh très facilement
et sur les terrains nous ce qu'on
souhaite bien sûr euh tous nos quatre
comités hein et puis on espère que tous
les comités
sportif de des ivelines et
d'île-de-fance applique l'esprit sportif
au maximum c'est que le le sport ça ça
redevienne si çait pas à un moment donné
de la joie de on appelle ça du jeu hein
dans quelques sport que ce soit on joue
au basket on joue au rand on joue au
rugby on joue au foot alors il y a pas
dans le mot jeu il y a aucune
agressivité donc on va essayer
d'inculquer à tous ces
ces personnes qui sont importantes les
éducateurs les arbitres les dirigeants
les présidents de club sont impliqués
euh just excusez-moi pi je vous coupe il
faut pas faire parler un peu tout le
monde sur sur ce plateau je me tourne
vers Armand Perrier Armand Perrier le
rugby c'est un sport de combat collectif
avec des athlètes impressionnants et
pourtant ces athlètes là que que que
tout le monde enfin tout le monde est
impressionné par ces athlètes mais il
respectent un homme sur le terrain c'est
l'arbitre comment déjà ses valeurs
sont-elles définies en le rugby et
est-ce que le rugby euh peut aider par
exemple un sport comme le football avec
ses valeurs transmises est-ce que ça
peut aider le football les valeurs du
rugby je je pense que nos valeurs euh
existent nous les cultivons nous
essayons de les garder je ne dis pas que
le foot n'essaye pas aussi puisque nous
venons d'entendre le président du comité
départemental de foot euh nous essayons
d'avoir un esprit de famille
nous y
ajoutons jeu convivialité
accueil mais il ne faut pas vendre la la
peau de l'ours nous avons eu quelques
difficultés aussi qui nous donne à
réfléchir ça nous donne à réfléchir pour
savoir pourquoi c'est arrivé et nous
nous rendons compte que ce n'est pas
toujours sur le terrain nous avons des
expériences pour le dire nous pouvons
aussi mettre nos arbitres avec des
superviseurs avec des directeurs de
match mais ce qui se passe c'est un
autre phénomène c'est le phénomène
extérieur ce qui se passe dans les
tribunes ce qui se passe après le match
nous en sommes peut-être responsable
mais nous ne sommes pas responsabl
réellement et je crois que c'est là
qu'il faut que nous essayion
de mutualiser toutes nos valeurs des
quadre sports que vous avez ce soir par
rapport à cette charte par rapport à ces
valeurs nous venons d'ajouter quelque
chose pour nous qui
permet j'ai pas dit que ça augmente le
temps de jeu ça le diminue c'est la
vidéo la vidéo nous permet pour
l'instant il y a un problème disons
est-ce qu'on doit mettre la vidéo
partout est-ce qu'on doit faire c on
doit faire ça pour nous elle nous permet
pour l'instant de déceler même dans ce
que l'on appelle le fairplay des actions
qui se sont déroulées une ou de minutes
avant et de revenir là-dessus
donc les arbitres oui pas vu pas pris
tandis que le maintenant ils sont pris
voilà c'est tout ce que je voulais dire
je me tourne vers notre dernier
interlocuteur Patrick Patrick cheab pour
le pour le
handb monsieur Perrier parlait à
l'instant des comportements dans les
tribunes je crois qu'il y a aussi ce
problème là dans LEB bien c'est LEB est
aussi confronté à ce genre de phénomène
il donc qu'il faut autant nos
disciplines mettent toutes les les
actions de formation mais il faut être
vigilance sur ce qui se passe comme a
dit Armand autour de des différentes
disciplines et le bal n'est pas exclu de
de ce phénomène on sent une petite
recrudescence dans les dans les tribunes
donc il faut y veiller absolument et
donc on espère que cette démarche va
aider à nous de la diffuser aussi auprès
de de nos disciplines merci Monsieur
pour avoir présenté cette initiative je
voulais vous demander d'ors et déjà
est-ce qu'il y a des démarches qui sont
qui sont prévues pour la suite Luc
miseray bah il y a déjà la poursuite des
échanges parce que là on a initié
certaines choses mais il y a la volonté
d'aller plus loin ensuite il y a les
expérimentations hein chaque comité
départemental va mettre en place les
formations sur les arbitres les
éducateurs sportifs les dirigeants pour
faire en sorte
de faire évoluer ces pratiques et puis
bah dans le même temps il y aura une
confrontation après pour euh de nouveau
mutualiser et voir si il faut aller plus
loin donc on est au tout début d'un d'un
processus qui vise à à faire en sorte
que bah à la fois il y a une
mutualisation hein mais vous disiez par
exemple qu'est-ce que le foot peut
apprendre du rugby le foot peut
apprendre de tout le monde mais surtout
ce qui sera déterminant pour lui ce sera
ce qu'il apprendra de lui-même et
comment il arrivera à faire en sorte de
de de dépasser les freins qui qui qu'il
a aujourd'hui c'est pareil pour chacun
de chacune des disciplines on espère que
cette initiative ira loin messieurs
merci beaucoup d'être venu en parler en
tout cas sur ce plateau aujourd'hui et
on passe tout de suite à la p à la page
tennis de
table mardi dernier les joueuses
d'élancour sont devenu championnes de
France de prob face au Club Athlétique
mayennaé elles accèdent du coup en ProA
et remplissent les objectifs du début de
saison retour sur cette prestation
mémorable dans une ambiance des grands
soirs pour cette rencontre face au Club
Athlétique mayennaé un parfum de pro à
flotte dans le palais des sports
d'ancour ce soir le CTT reçoit le
premier du championnat de probédame et
pour les deux équipes la victoire est
synonyme d'accession au plus haut niveau
français l'entraîneur Fran solniier ne
s'y trompe pas et à ligne d'entrée sa
meilleure joueuse Eva oderova ne fait
d'ailleurs qu'une bouchée d'océanner 37
à0
en cour mène la danse mais le prochain
match s'annonce compliqué audrearif à
peine 15 ans affronte l'expérimenté
dibao l'international junior a beau se
démener elle multiplie les fautes
techniques et s'incline en manches dans
le 3è match yananang redonne l'avantage
àcour grâce à une partie globalement
maîtrisée enencour mène alors 2 et le 4
match entreorova et dibao s clairement
la
poudre
la rencontre propose au public bouillant
une belle intensité à un partout la fin
de la 3è manche est un tournant la
Slovaque en difficulté est mené 11 12 la
suite de l'histoire se passe de
commentair
evaorova remporte finalement 4 à1 cette
confrontation un match qu'elle est allé
chercher au mental c'est un match
c'était un set très très serin mais je
pense qu'avec les avec l'expérience que
que j'ai même si c'est une joueuse très
très expérimentée aussi en face mais
avec encouragement avec la volonté
surtout parce que je voulais vraiment
absolument gagner et je pense que avec
la volonté j'ai gagné yananang termine
le travail en 4 manche face à océan
Hebner et encours est sacré champion de
France de probé à TR journées de la fin
une satisfaction pour Franck solniier au
regard du potentiel de l'équipe et de la
bonne saison de ses joueuses même si
l'entraîneur élan courtois s'attend à un
tout autre niveau l'an prochain en
première division ça n'a rien à voir ça
vraiment il y a un fossé il y a un très
gros fossé entre cette division là et
celle du dessus l'année prochaine on va
voir des super matchs avec un super
niveau de jeu parce que le championnat
de France est un des meilleurs
championnats d'Europe avec l'Allemagne
nous on essaiera de se maintenir déjà
parce que on arrive on va être les
petits Pousset de de la division on va
essayer d'avoir un objectif déjà de
maintien puis on on va se bagarrer quoi
les trois derniers match sans enjeu vont
permettre de débuter la prép de la
saison prochaine et de faire tourner
l'effectif un effectif qui verra au
moins arriver une nouvelle joueuse la
saison
prochaine les résultats sportifs
yvelinois et on commence avec du
football en DH Versailles obtient un
match nul à l'extérieur et conforte sa
place de 7e au championnat il reste à 6
points du 3e mais avec deux matchs de
retard en Promotion Honneur pouleb 0 à0
entre torsy et trappe dans la poucé
Logne et Guy encour font match nul
également Guy encour reste avant-dernier
du
championnat football toujours et une
nouvelle défaite pour les joueuses de
Montini le Bretonneux en 2e division
cette fois elle s'incline 2 à1 à
domicile contre Compiègne pourtant après
de buts encaissés à cause d'erreurs
individuelles elles vont réduire l'écart
mais malgré une bonne deuxième mi-temps
elle ne reviendront jamais au score une
4è défaite consécutive forcément amère
pour les inontaines dernière au
classement à 5 journées de la fin pour
autant leur entraîneur jean-dan Grosset
refuse d'abdiquer concernant le maintien
en 2e division comme j'avais dit dans le
vaissè on a six étapes je pense que la
première étape est loupée et il reste c
il faut y croire moi j'y crois avec ce
qu'on a produit aujourd'hui il faut y
croire jusqu'à la fin la saison n'est
pas terminée il faut voir les résultats
de devant et on fera le point à la fin
je pense que beaucoup de monde nous voit
en d mais c'est pas fini on vair 15
joureur pour préparer le match de
valdorge je pense que ça va être un
tournant de la saison je pense que même
si on prend match après match je pense
que valdorge sera vraiment le tournant
de la saison pour savoir si on descend
en DH ou si on est maintenu en
d2ose à saintmort 26 à 19 des Plaisirois
qui ont marqué quatre essai et qui
restent 2e de leur poule en fédéral 3 en
basket ont joué la dernière journée du
championnat de National 3 poissi
s'impose 73 à 67 à domicile contre
l'Entente le chaînet Versailles dans la
même poule le ministère des Finances
gagne 68 à 49 face à trappe c'était la
dernière journée et c'est gravanchon qui
termine premier et accède à la Nationale
2 en bal et la victoire de Montini en
Nationale 2 contre le dernier de la
poule hasbrook score final 27 à 20
Montini reste 5e en volé Montini
sincline 37 à0 contre Vincenne dans la
dernière journée de championnat de
régional 1 même tarif pour plaisir à
domicile contre
Sartrouville enfin en baseball les
cougard de Montini font un partout
contre les Red Wings de Rennes enfin en
foot US défaite des Templiers d en cours
34 à 20 face au flash de la cour neuve
on termine avec deux rendez-vous dans
l'agenda la Coupe de France de BMX tout
d'abord au Vélodrome de51 en yeline les
12 et 13 avril d'ailleurs samedi de 18h
à 22h ne manquez pas le show freestyle
VTT BMX à l'intérieur du v rome la
rondeb des butineuses c'est dimanche à
la base de loisir de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline avec notamment son trail de 26
km dès 9h du matin temps maximum 3h30 il
ne faudra donc pas trop
butiner voilà c'est tout pour ce 78
sport la semaine prochaine vous avez à
nouveau rendez-vous avec Anthony rche
qui prenait un peu de repos merci de
nous avoir suivi excellente soirée sur
TVfil